[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la sphère damien abad
qui empoisonnent l'exécutif nommé
ministre malgré des accusations de viol
l'intéressé nie en bloc et refuse de
démissionner jusqu'où la présomption
d'innocence doit-elle prix mais doit-on
privilégier la parole des femmes au nom
d'un principe de précaution est ça la
justice seule de trancher question de
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
nos invités notre grand témoin elle se
bat depuis des années pour le
rapatriement des enfants de djihadiste
français détenus en syrie avec plusieurs
associations elles demandent à être
reçus par emmanuel macron avocate
pénaliste soprano du barreau elle défend
aussi l'un des accusés dans le procès
des attentats du 13 novembre les
plaidoiries commencé hier marie dosé est
avec nous ce soir enfin nous trouverons
nous affranchit pour leur parti pris le
carnet de campagne des deux mondes un
gars passionné législatives la politique
avec jean rémi baudot le maquereau nisme
peut-il survivre à emmanuel macron est
une économie fanny guinochet quand la
pénurie d'eau lithium paralyse toute la
filière automobile voilà promu c'est
parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs 48 heures après laffaire
abad ne retombe pas des associations
féministes réclament la démission du
nouveau ministre des solidarités elles
manifestent ce soir à paris alors
comment le gouvernement d'elisabeth
borne à peine nommé at il pu se mettre
dans un tel pétrin et comment les partis
politiques doivent réagir lorsqu'ils
sont alertés on en parle avec vous ce
soir à nathalie tommasini bonsoir vous
êtes avocate au barreau de paris et
spécialiste ces questions de violence
sexuelle et sexiste bonsoir christophe
barbier bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
éditorialiste politique à bfm tv et à
francs tireurs bonsoir christian
saint-palais m saint-palais ravi de vous
retrouver sur un plateau avocat
également barreau de paris et puis
camilla chaise co secrétaire fédéral à
des jeunes écologistes va nous rejoindre
dans un tout petit instant mais pour
nous rappeler les faits et nous planter
le décor ces jeux se dire le billet de
stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien compris
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens riam bonsoir à
tout si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris myriam pour s'en tenir
aux faits comme vous dites il ya deux
femmes qui accusent donc damien abad de
les avoir violées pour résumer un peu
l'accusation la première dit qu'elle a
invité damas damien bas de chez elle
c'était en 2010 donc ils ont passé la
soirée fait l'amour une première fois
avec son consentement donc jusque là ça
reste dans leur intimité sauf que il ya
eu un deuxième rapport qui aurait lieu
sans le consentement de la femme dont
qui a porté plainte en 2012 une première
fois n'a pas été au bout de sa démarche
puis en 2017 ou là la justice a classé
la plainte sans suite on aurait pu
croire que damien balle était innocenté
n'empêche ce week end à eelv est borgne
était dans le calvados elle fait
campagne où serait pour être élu député
on ne lui parlait que de damien abad en
écoute moi j'ai découvert l'article de
mediapart hier j'ai pas plus d'éléments
que le fait que l' affaire a été classée
sans suite je vous assurer qu'il ya des
nouveaux éléments si la justice est à
nouveau saisi on tirera toutes les
conséquences de cette décision en clair
sida bien bas des mises en examen il
doit quitter le gouvernement l axe de
procédure il faut les entendre mise en
examen ne veut pas dire mise en examen
puisque dupond moretti est mise en
examen non plus n'a pas l'intention de
virer dupond-moretti mais en fait
effectivement damien abad et est sous le
coup d'une seconde accusation puisque
dans mediapart ils ont repéré un autre
témoignage qui dit pour résumer que une
femme donc accepté une invitation de la
part de damien abad ils ont dîné elle a
bu un verre de champagne black out elle
ne se souvient de rien jusqu'au moment
où tu sors ta paye le lendemain dans un
appartement avec damien abad donc c'est
difficile d'établir dramont accusations
sur un trou noir mais on comprend bien
que c'est l'idée de la drogue du violeur
on a envie d'entendre quand même damien
abad qu'est ce qu'il a à répondre à ça
donc ils des geeks c'est complètement
faux qui n'a jamais violé personne et
puis comme raison supplémentaire pour
dire mais croyez-moi il dit que c'était
impossible à cause de son handicap c'est
à dire que il n'arrive même pas à
s'habiller et se déshabille et tout cela
pour qu'est-ce qu'on peut se déshabille
sahin violé quelqu'un sans se
déshabiller quand on est déshabillé
comment fait pour se rhabiller si on
vient le terme être un crime on écoute
damien abad j'ai toujours évité de
mettre mon handicap en avant j'étais
contraint malheureusement de le faire
aujourd'hui pour me défendre et même de
dévoiler mon intimité en détail en
expliquant que les faits qui mettait
imputé était matériellement impossible
là on est à la limite de l'agglo créé
par m j'imagine que l'opposition
instrumentalisé profite de cette affaire
un petit peu en triomphe rockets qui
soit assez fort et les filles en tête le
nip s on va dire parce qu'ils y vont
tous a pas encore la semaine dernière
les accusés d'avoir aidé d'être prêt
la forêt investiture à taïwan ils sont
portés une manière évidemment on espère
tous comprendre très répréhensible avec
les femmes donc cette semaine changement
de rôle les voilà en position d'accusé
heure ce qu'ils peuvent reprocher au
gouvernement ce qu'on leur reprochait la
semaine dernière donc je vous propose
d'écouter mathilde viau c'est elle qui
mène la campagne contre damien abad et
elle est membre des relais filles on en
arrive encore à une fausse grande cause
du quinquennat c'est à dire que les
violences sexistes et sexuelles en
politique
n'intéresse pas le gouvernement on le
savait déjà avec le maintien de gérald
darmanin en tant que ministre donc
effectivement moi je gagne dit qu'ils
étaient très forts et les filles en même
temps ils sont un peu inquiétants
puisque la part de gérald darmanin qui
n'aurait pas dû être au gouvernement ou
aux dernières nouvelles jean gérald
darmanin le parquet a requis un non lieu
contre lui le juge ne l'a pas mis en
examen donc c'est un peu à peu jusqu'à
quel moment on est innocent quand la
justice mais vous accuse de rien ce
qu'on peut encore être considérée comme
coupable au point de ne pas pouvoir
filtrant débattent mais quand on écoute
quand même les témoignages s'était fait
damien abad et pressants on peut dire ce
mot là avec ces femmes être même lourde
après centre est lourdingue son salaire
d'effectivement de faire une certaine
unanimité autour de diam inde amir valle
donc est ce que c'est pour autant de
raisons suffisantes pour l'écarter d'un
gouvernement ben en tout cas c'est ce
que pensent les féministes évidemment
mais pas seulement s'associer ce que
pense marine le pen j'ai uniquement dit
qu'il semblait puisque beaucoup de
langues se délient qu'il avait
l'habitude d'avoir à l'égard des femmes
un comportement ou des propos
inappropriés que rien que cela
m'apparaissait de voir les cartes et
d'un poste de ministre surtout d'un
gouvernement qui a fait de la lutte pour
la défense des femmes sa priorité
donc est-ce que damien band peut rester
au gouvernement je m'en vais vous êtes
là pour débattre et merci beaucoup merci
stéphane bern va se la poser cette
question au fond est-ce que c'est à la
justice seule de trancher vous qui est
avocate nathalie tommasini ou est ce que
il y à ce principe de précaution que
certaines féministes met en avant dans
ses affaires écouter la parole des
femmes qui doit primer le principe de
précaution sur la justice ou la justice
sur ce principe vous avez presque
répondu à la question
aujourd'hui à l'heure de la libération
de la parole des femmes bien évidemment
le principe de précaution doit doit
nécessairement prévaloir sur la
présomption d'innocence expliquez-nous
ce que c'est ce principe de précaution
en l'espèce le principe de précaution
pour moi il est très simple on nomme un
ministre alors que l'on sait
pertinemment
c'est un secret de polichinelle qu'il
avait un comportement de drague lourde
envers les femmes on a un signalement et
pas n'importe lequel à un signalement de
l'observatoire des violences sexistes et
sexuelles qui est transmis à la fois où
l air une semaine après la nomination au
l air à la république aux marches ou là
par mail vous le savez est transmis par
même s'il ne l'avait pas est ainsi
couvert arqués et ainsi qu'au parquet
donc on voit bien que là ce n'est pas
simplement la parole de la femme mais
qui a eu des professionnels qui se sont
penchés sur des déclarations de cette
femme puisqu'elle n'avait même pas osé
déposer plainte et c'est l'observatoire
des violences sexistes et sexuelles qui
transmet un signalement dont catherine
viau qu'on a entendues a été une des
représentantes absolument donc pour des
faits qui remontent à 2010 2011 des
faits relativement anciens mais
effectivement la réputation de habad est
entachée par le fait qu'il n'y a pas
qu'une seule femme mais il y en a deux
pour des faits beaucoup plus récent de
2017 alors moi je veux bien entendre la
rhétorique de damien abad qui précise
qu'il est atteint d'une maladie rare
qu'il est handicapé et qu'il a un
problème de mobilité sourire qu'il a été
surtout une en santé pardo classement
sans suite non il ya c'est ce qui s'est
passé non il ya eu un classement 5 la
vie ce moment et est
maintenant en tant qu'avocate avec mon
expérience dans ce domaine un classement
sans suite ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il n'y a rien et qu'il n'y a
pas d'élément important qui
qui caractérise hongrie mais les
violences je rappelle qu'il ya quand
même 80 % de classement sans suite sur
les plaintes déposées par victimes de
violences sexuelles ne savent barbier
l'existence même de ces accusations rend
intenable selon m tommasini la position
au sein du gouvernement de damien abad
c'est une tendance qui m'inquiète
beaucoup si l'accusation vos
condamnations n'y a plus d'état de droit
possibles si la réputation
entraîne l'élimination par exemple pour
des fonctions politiques jusqu'où
va-t-on s'arrêter parce qu'on pourrait
dire que si la drague lourde interdit
d'être ministre c'est pas bien des
trains lourdingue bas la colère et se
mettre en colère contre les gens hurler
contre les gens ben doit aussi interdire
les gens d'être ministre parce qu'on se
comporte pas comme ça quand on est avec
des collaborateurs d'emploi de se mettre
en colère vous venez d'éliminer de la
vie politique quelqu'un qui a présidé
cette assemblée ici c'est philippe
séguin qui est lancée des dossiers à
travers la pièce qui se mettait en
colère tout le temps donc si la
réputation de valloire élimination de
certaines fonctions je pense qu'on va
vers une forme de deux sociétés de la
terreur et du robespierrisme son compte
et christian sans compter des
acquisitions sans compter que il suffira
pour éliminer quelqu'un de l'accusé donc
ça sera la prime au mensonge évidemment
la prime aux mensonges et aux mythomane
ça se retournera contre les vraies
victimes parce qu'on n'entendra plus les
vrais plein des vraies victimes si un
jour on constate qu'il ya eu une deux ou
trois fautes accusations uniquement pour
nuire vraiment si la sanction n'est plus
la sanction judiciaire mais la sanction
sociétale si on se dit et c'est vrai
hélas que parce que dans ces affaires de
violences sexuelles la justice est trop
lente que souvent elle et elle est
impuissante et le dis on n'y arrivera
pas on n'a pas de preuve et bien puisque
la justice est impuissante il faut
remplacer sa part une peine sociale où
l'homme accusé peut-être un jour la
femme ça arrive que des femmes soient
accusés de harcèlement et bien sont
éliminés de toute fonction publique
parce que simplement ils ont été accusés
alors là on va vers une société très
dangereux à l'arrêt pense exactement la
ligne que défend le président de la
république il la devait vraiment bien
expliqué le 14 juillet on va l'écouter
mais j'aimerais bien mettre saint-palais
vous soumettre quand même ce témoignage
sait jamais c'est jamais facile de
témoigner voilà quand on s'estime
victime quand on est victime
d'agression sexuelle
tu appelles margot c'est un nom
d'emprunt c'est l'une des deux victimes
présumées de damien abad elle a témoigné
sur france info hier et il s'agit d'une
ex militante centriste aujourd'hui âgée
de 35 ans elle raconte pourquoi après
une première tentative on le disait elle
à elle a finalement porté plainte en
2010 est écouté ce que j'espère c'est
que la sortie dans la presse de cette
affaire empêche d'autres victimes
permettent à d'autres victimes
éventuelles de parler j'ai porté plainte
au commissariat un an après mais j'ai
pas réussi à signer aller jusqu'au bout
mais s'ils ont plus tard j'ai réussi à
le faire c'est parce que la garde a été
omniprésent dans les médias et que je
peux plus supporter juste de le voir
d'en souffrir et que lui ne soit
inquiété en rien moi j'ai eu un examen
médico légal et lui qui affirme ne pas
pouvoir à cause de son handicap fait ce
qu'il a faire n'a pas eu des amants si
on était assez simple pourtant de
pouvoir trouver qu'il est capable par un
médecin christian saint-palais qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on a ce genre de
témoignage alors on parle de signalement
par des professionnels de l'écouté du
recueil de la parole des femmes et des
victimes présumées il ya des entreprises
quand il ya une difficulté manifeste
sans être dans un cadre judiciaire on
vous met à pied ou vous on vous renvoie
sur un autre post je pose des questions
est ce que vous considérez que on doit
aller vers ça ou comme christophe
barbier la présomption d'innocence doit
primer et seule la justice doit trancher
je crois qu'on peut conjuguer légumes
les deux la présomption d'innocence doit
primer vous savez il y a encore cinq
années je crois on aurait entendu un
membre du barreau tenir les propos que
vous avez tenus cher consoeurs je crois
que nous aurions été encore plus édifié
que je le suis aujourd'hui mais je suis
encore très édifié d'entendre dire qu'on
pourrait renoncer à la présomption
d'innocence
là vraiment c'est le fondement de l'état
de droit mais nous avons nous avons
combien d'exemples d'hommes que de
femmes mise en cause pendant un certain
temps qui ont perdu leur honneur qui se
sont défendus et que la justice a
innocenté parce qu'ils étaient innocents
de ignition minutes devant dit je pense
à lui bien sûr mais en fait tout le
monde connaît des visages et publics et
autour de soi nous avons chacun des
hommes et des femmes mises en cause qui
ont perdu leur honneur et qui ont été
innocentés au thème la procédure
fallait-il les exclus ur de notre groupe
social parce qu'ils étaient mis en cause
alors vous avez dit tout à l'heure
principe de précaution ou présomption
d'innocence il faut quand même protégé
attention la présomption d'innocence
avec la justice on protège cependant
vous pouvez être mise en examen présumé
innocent est cependant placé en
détention si le juge je pense qu'il ya
des indices de risque à l'égard d'autrui
bien sûr que c'est possible dans une
entreprise
si vous êtes si un homme en contact avec
des mineurs par exemple est mise en
cause est ce qu'il ne faut pas
s'interroger sur la précaution et de la
parole de la plaignante parce que
d'abord ne parlons pas de victimes
soyons les uns et des autres dans nos
métiers résumé c'est non c'est bien
précisément de dire nous plaignons
uniquement sur les mises en cause la
deuxième victime présumée mais guy mais
n'a pas porté chance à vous dire ne
disons pas victime présumée restons les
uns et les autres dans nos domaines
respectifs très précis pour que
justement notre état de droit fonctionne
bien que les plaignants puisse
s'exprimer librement parce qu'il faut
repayer la parole il faut qu'ils
puissent s'exprimer et les mises en
cause se défendre pleinement nous allons
nous pouvons y arriver quand quelqu'un
dont se plaint bien sûr qu'il faut le
protéger s'il est dans une société et
qu'il faut que cette jeune femme si elle
se plaint de violences sexuelles
commises par un supérieur hiérarchique
il faut organiser la société pendant
qu'on mène des investigations de façon à
ce qu'elle ne soit pas victime de
pension et on le phare ganivelles
associés
écarté rendre sans pour autant les mi
journée
journaliste récemment mises à pied et
interpeller publiquement par une femme
politique candidate à la présidence en
disant je refuserais presque de vous
parler je vais faire un petit effort par
rapport à mes électeurs potentiels et
que la justice pour lequel la justice a
dit il n'y a pas lieu de suivre parce
que c'est la loi attention nous parlons
de la loi quand le parquet classe sans
suite il ya eu une enquête et parce que
les preuves n'étaient pas réunies eh
bien le parquet a dit nous classons sans
suite nous ne pouvons pas aller plus
loin c'est là que nous avons votée on
s'en va s'interroger aussi sur ce que
pouvait savoir ou non le gouvernement
avec ces signalements je voudrais quand
même accueillir camille hs pardonnez moi
je vous redonne la parole c'est promis
j'aime bien comme les invités envie de
parler mais vous inquiétez pas ça va
venir camilla chaise vous êtes jeunes
écologistes c'est ça rappelez-moi
cofondatrice à je n'ai plus votre titre
sous les yeux de secrétaire comme
secrétaire fédéral des jeunes
écologistes et vous faire écouter on
peut l'appeler la jurisprudence macron
mais m saint palais c'est la
jurisprudence de la présomption
d'innocence mais c'était intéressant
c'est le 14 juillet dernier il a
longuement expliqué à la faveur d'une
question sur gérald darmanin qui au
moment où il s'exprimait elle n'avait
pas été donc l'objet de ce non-lieu
requis par le procureur écouter aucune
cause n'est défendu justement si on le
fait en bafouant les principes
fondamentaux de notre démocratie et je
le dis pour un ministre comme je le
dirai pour quelques citoyens que ce soit
je suis aussi de là où je me place le
garant de cette présomption d'innocence
et je le dis dans les rapports aussi que
notre vie démocratique pourrait avoir
avec notre vie judiciaire
si à partir du moment où quelqu'un est
accusé
n'est pas jugée
il devient en quelque sorte la victime
d'un jugement de rue ou de réseaux
sociaux alors s'impose le choix
politiques démocratiques de dire celui
ci ou celle là ne peut pas avoir de
responsabilités politiques mais vous
n'avez notre démocratie change de nature
elle devient une démocratie d'opinion
voilà le jugement de rue camille achète
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous
écoutez cette parole qui le président se
dit lui même d'une certaine manière de
là où il parle garant de la présomption
d'innocence
vous êtes d'accord
alors nous écologistes bien sûr que pour
nous la présomption d'innocence c'est
une de valeur qu'on respecte totalement
il pas question
de outrepassé la justice et d'émettre un
jugement sur est ce que monsieur hamad
est coupable ou pas ça sera la justice
qui le dira
néanmoins on pense qu'il faut écouter la
parole des victimes on a sept cette
femme donc margot qui témoignent du fait
qu'il est difficile de porter plainte
qu'elle a essayé et que finalement elle
n'est pas allée au bout de la démarche
est que là on l'a en voyant monsieur à
battre constamment dans les médias elle
a eu envie mais à l'écouter lui donner
une place particulière qu'est ce que ça
a comme conséquence pour vous la
démission de damien abad forcément pour
nour est très clair c'est la démission
d'accord au moins le temps de l'enquète
c'est à dire qu'en fait si monsieur abad
et finalement dispense ion quoi innocent
il pour être totalement réintégrer dans
un gouvernement seulement aujourd'hui on
dit que il faut pas mettre l'opprobe sur
monsieur ahmed mais finalement ce sont
les victimes qui
présumés on ne peut pas dire victime
présumée apparemment mais sont ces
femmes et ceux qui souffrent nathalie
tommasini oui je voulais rebondir sur ce
qui a été dit par mon confrère
j'allais dire presque mon contradicteur
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait dont le
contexte qui était celui du gouvernement
macron qui a voulu faire de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
une priorité qui fallait donner la
primeur effectivement au principe de
précaution par rapport à la présomption
d'innocence
je m'explique le message qui est envoyé
par le gouvernement des manuels macron
par la nomination de damien abad qui est
suspecté entre guillemets donc de viol
est un message qui est totalement
contradictoire pour les victimes et qui
ne peuvent pas ne pas réagir à cette
nomination
moi je trouve qu'on est finalement prise
en otage par cette domination par cette
nomination parce que domination oui
voilà on est pris en otage parce que
maintenant la question se pose de savoir
s'il faut qu'il démissionne
ou pas mais il aurait fallu en amour
alors s'interroger sur cette
personnalité il n'y avait pas d'autres
ministres a nommé que damien abad qui
était connu pour sa drague lourde envers
les femmes alors on n'est rien il y
avait également ce magazine closer qui
s'était fait l'écho à l'époque de ce
viol en 2010 est donc tout le monde
savait de cette plainte les errements de
la plainte pour viol quand j'entends
elisabeth bordjiens je n'étais pas au
courant je ne peux pas le croire je vous
propose de regarder tout de suite ce
sujet de thibaut enoch le gouvernement
pouvait-il ignorer l'existence des
plaintes en tout cas et la bête bornes
vous l'avez compris et bien la firme
regardez
l'elysée et matignon pouvait-il être au
courant que damien abad avait fait
l'objet d'une plainte pour violence
sexuelle en mars 2010 est la réponse
n'est pas simple et implique de passer
en revue les différents outils qui
aurait pu alerte l'exécutif premiers
éléments le casier judiciaire dans le
cas de damien abad la plainte ayant été
classée sans suite en décembre 2017 il
était vierge seuls les condamnations et
figurants un autre officier aurait
cependant pu garder trace de la plainte
il s'agit du fichier de traitement des
antécédents judiciaires
une fiche y est créé lors d'un dépôt de
plainte en temps normal elle doit être
détruite en cas de classement sans suite
mais par manque de moyens et de temps ce
n'est pas toujours le cas autre canal
d'alert la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique créé en
2013 après laffaire cahuzac cette
instance contrôler la situation des
ministres avant leur entrée en fonction
cependant elle ne pouvait pas avoir
connaissance d'une procédure judiciaire
relative aux moeurs la haute autorité ne
s'intéressant qu'à la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts et à la situation
financière des élus dernier outil dont
dispose le gouvernement les remontées
d'informations à la chancellerie
le ministère de la justice est en effet
mis au courant par les parquets des
dossiers sensibles notamment ceux visant
des personnalités politiques
ces remontées se font en temps réel en
2017 emmanuel macron était déjà au
pouvoir en théorie son ministre de la
justice pouvait donc être au courant
cependant damien abad n'était alors pas
une personnalité de premier plan et
n'intéressait pas nécessairement
l'exécutif là encore une fois la plainte
classer le dossier à l'époque a dû être
clôturée
caisse tabarly ou connaissait très bien
la vie politique française et de longue
date est il vraiment possible que
emmanuel macron
c'est peu probable il est fortement
probable que emmanuel macron le savez ne
serait ce que par le le bruit politique
mais entre le savoir et en avoir une
information officielle par une autorité
dont la fonction est de dire voilà
pourquoi on peut nommer voilà pourquoi
on ne peut pas nommer c'est une
différence avec l rationalité
s'il savait qu'une plainte avait été
classée sans suite c'est l'heure il n'y
avait donc pas matière à poursuivre donc
il était innocent ils ne sont pleins et
entiers la vérité judiciaire la verrine
ailière la politique mais le risque
n'est pas trop important mais si on va
dans le sens de la rumeur de la
réputation on ne s'arrête pas violé
quelqu'un c'est intolérable une
agression sexuelle c'est intolérable
nous aider la galerie mais la drague
lourde au contraire aujourd'hui même si
elle fait l'objet une juste condamnation
sociale
ne fait pas l'objet d'une condamnation
légal vous n'êtes pas condamné pour être
lourd donc si pour être lourd tout
dépend si satie ça devient du
harcèlement ou de l'agression oui mais
si c'est simplement parce que vous êtes
lourd ça ne tient pas à sa défensive et
il est question de damien abad
relativement harcelant alors avec les
ports tellement de drague il était
condamné pour harcèlement non y at il
une enquête parce que moi je retiens
cette proposition oui quand une enquête
est ouverte le temps de l'enquète on
peut demander à quelqu'un de se retirer
de ses fonctions quand elles sont
publiques c'est ce qui est pratiqué
depuis la jurisprudence dit bernard
tapie est un peu après balladur parce
que enquête il ya est ce qu'il ya une
enquête sur damien
iehl information judiciaire
c'était la mise en examen est ce que la
mise en examen doit rester le curseur ou
est-ce qu'on doit te descendent le
change c'est plus la règle et vous le
savez bien puis saillard haïti et je le
redis
que déjà dans le temps passe et la mise
en examen ça ne suffisait pas quand il
avait diffamation parce que c'est une
mise en examen est automatique au moulin
de royal avait démissionné très
bien ce qu'est mis
le curseur est bien élevé mais on peut
considérer que les magistrats qui l'ont
mis en examen sont dans un combat
corporatiste c'est ce que dira la
défense de dupond moretti et on
cherchait justement à l'éliminer du
pouvoir alors on peut glisser
le curseur est très difficile et la
justice de ce côté là du débat qui doit
trancher et elle seule à quel moment
quand elle tranche c'est à dire qu'on a
tout les jurisprudences françois bayrou
a démissionné début 2017 quand il est
une simple enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte on a une affaire de rugy dans un
contexte très différent ou le homard qui
n'est absolument pas lié à aucune
plainte que ce soit a provoqué une
démission aujourd'hui un garde des
sceaux de mise en examen toujours en
fonction oui pour la justice mais qu'on
ait quitté qu'il fixe la règle mais
c'est pour ça que j'invite chacun à
respecter des principes fondamentaux
puisque la vo cité des décisions
individuelles ou collectives d'ailleurs
mais politique c'est vrai que les hommes
politiques qui sont visés par une
plainte peuvent se dire je vais
tellement coûté en poids à mon équipe
gouvernementale que j'ai l'élégance de
la quitter et peut-être va-t-on leur
conseiller souvent de la quitter en
disant on va être rv et de feuilletons
de médiapart pendant des semaines donc
évidemment c'est un poids pour une
équipe gouvernementale
mais ça je dirais que c'est un choix
particulier peut-être y at-il d'ailleurs
un signal politique fort et qui me
plairait je vous le dis au risque de
vous choquer du président macron nous
avions des réquisitions juste avant la
composition du gouvernement aux
réquisitions quand même du procureur
général maulin demandant le renvoi
d'eric dupond moretti devant la
juridiction et le non lieu pour et
rigueur c'était un signe assez fort qui
avait la mise en examen mais en plus des
réquisitions de saisine de la cour de
justice de la république
nous nous sommes tous dit là c'est fini
pour dupont
non mais voyez le saigne politique le
signe politique c'est de dire il est
mise en examen ça c'est l'application
stricte des principes dont nous avons
besoin il est innocent si je pense que
politiquement il peut être là et il
assume ça si c'est un choix je vous
assure ça me plaît ça ne veut pas dire
parce qu'ensuite on caricature notre
propos quand nous le tenons ainsi on dit
vous je sais que ce que l'on veut dire
vous méprise riez la parole des
plaignantes mais non ça n'a rien à voir
alors nous sommes avocat et nous
recevons autant de plaignons que de
mises en cause dans nos cabinets
respectifs
je sais la difficulté qu'il ya à porter
une parole de l'euthanasie ce n'est pas
qu'elle ya seize mois ça qui m'intéresse
c'est le travail des partis et le rôle
qu'ont les parties on a vu ce qui s'est
passé avec la ferte aboaf dans cette
cellule des couteaux sein de la france
insoumise des écologistes ont
l'équivalent fait tout à fait qu'est ce
qui se passe parce qu'on se dit il n'y a
pas de plaintes à ma connaissance dans
la sphère boîte même si d'après ce qu'on
comprend les faits reprochés sont d'une
grande gravité qu'est ce que vous dites
là on a bien fait d'utiliser une sorte
de justice politique ou en tout cas
d'organes politique pour débrancher
pardonnez moi l'expression mais de la
candidature aux législatives en amont où
là encore c'est la justice et il
faudrait qu'au fond seule la justice
peut se permettre de juger en toute
légitimité le d'abord le candidat l'ex
candidat quelques est qu'on fait là on a
on a des partis et on à la justice
en fait moi je vais déjà revenir sur ces
procédures qui existent dans les
entreprises enfin et dans les
administrations lorsqu'il y à une
accusation en interne on peut avoir des
enquêtes parallèles à celles de la
justice pour prendre des mesures par
exemple
d'éloignement ou ce genre de choses en
fait la logique est la même dans nos
partis c'est à dire que on n'attend pas
la justice prenne une décision on a des
instances de avec des personnes qui sont
formés à l'écouté des victimes et
également
c'est souvent le cas dans les
candidatures dans des élections mais
vous pourriez le faire en cas de mandat
électif en cours
tout à fait faire en sorte que voilà un
élu bon ça n'est pas très fréquent dans
la jurisprudence ne va pas encore ce cas
là mais là c'est vrai que dans le cas de
tabous apps nathalie tommasini on a
affaire à quelque chose d'assez nouveau
il faut que ça se généralise
ou est ce que vous vous dites ce soir
tout de même dans la sphère boivent
c'est préférable que la justice passe et
il faut qu'elle soit saisie non je suis
exactement sur la même ligne que madame
et je trouve que effectivement on ne
peut pas attendre que la justice passe
est ce que vous savez est ce que vous
connaissez les délais
plusieurs années parfois merci et je
voudrais rebondir également sur ce qui a
été évoqué par mon confrère
quand on parle de présomption
d'innocence je veux bien mais est-ce que
vous vous rappelez quand députés rm a
quand même s'est présenté aux
législatives et que lui avait été
condamné pour violence conjugale et il a
quand même été soutenu par emmanuel
macron il a démissionné devant le tollé
des féministes référent ce que je veux
la candidature de jérôme peyrat qui a
décidé de lui même de fausses et raymond
donc je veux dire on est dans un
gouvernement
qui communique tout azimuts sur le fléau
des violences conjugales la nécessité
absolue de l'endiguer et on a message
totalement contradictoire incroyable
c'est contradictoire avec la grande
cause et cac et la région nous sommes
avocats l'un et l'autre est-ce que vous
pensez que lorsque quelqu'un est
condamné que la justice ce qui en a la
possibilité
parce que la loi ne le prévoit pas parce
que le tribunal ne l'a pas des cités ne
l'a pas déclaré inéligible ou ne l'a pas
déclaré inapte à des fonctions est ce
que vous pensez vous êtes avocat comme
mais oui et vous pensez donc que on doit
jeter l'opprobre sur un homme mais qu'il
n'a pas été condamné mais me déclarer
coupable c'est le faire autant que aveu
qu'a lâché non aux citoyens dont
citoyens revient sur ce principe que les
avocats devant connaître là je met en
parallèle la priorité gouvernementale
qui est 2 d'endiguer
le chanteur de police mais messi mais en
l'état on est obligé de faire de la
politique là en l'occurrence c'est à
dire que vous reprochez à la majorité on
peut le comprendre d'avoir été trop
indulgente envers un personnage dont la
condamnation vu les valeurs professée
par ce quinquennat ne méritait pas
l'investiture ça s'entend tout à fait
mais il faudrait savoir si on doit aller
plus loin et considéré que pour un
certain nombre de délits ceux là où
d'autres par exemple voler de l'argent
public il doit y avoir une peine
d'inéligibilité automatique quand on a
commis ses fonctions il qu'on veut
il ya une forme d'appréciation et à
l'appréciation politique bien que
l'appréciation de la valeur et la
cohérence la cohérence du discours bien
sûr c'est pourquoi t'as aboaf n'aurait
jamais dû être investi non pas pour ses
affaires qui heureusement été révélé
mais pour ses propos sur charlie hebdo
d'autres bugs fusil de logique voilà je
vous propose dans tout cas et la société
et la justice avance quand on regarde le
nombre d'affaires qui ont éclaté en
matière politique notamment d'affaires
sexuelle va faire une une sorte de tour
d'horizon si je puis me permettre avec
marco premier
c'est l'une des pionnières de la
libération de la parole en 2011 tristane
banon poursuit dominique strauss kahn
pour tentative de viol des faits
remontant à février 2003 mais qu'elle
raconte dès 2007 dans une émission de
thierry ardisson à l'époque personne
n'est surpris de cette histoire donc non
seulement ils sont pas surpris mais
connaissent l'histoire et ils ont
l'occasion lâché devant eux et ils
veulent juste les détails et d'ailleurs
il les pose la question sur les détails
comment ça s'est passé et alors itami ou
d'abord et ça c est ça s'est enchaîné
comment es tu es à la fin commenté parti
c'est ça qui nous intéresse c'est le
côté sulfureux longtemps méprisé il
faudra attendre la sphère du sofitel de
new york pour que la romancière soit
enfin écoutés tristane banon la première
à briser l'omerta mais pas la dernière
en 2011 deux ex-employées municipales
accusent georges tron maire de ravel de
viol et d'agression sexuelle alors
secrétaire d'état il quitte le
gouvernement de françois fillon mais
clame son innocence de retour dans sa
commune ses partisans le soutiennent
face à ses adversaires
[Musique]
l avant
georges tron sera condamné en appel à
cinq ans de prison dont trois ans ferme
en 2017 la libération de la parole
s'accélère c'est le début d'un mouvement
d'ampleur celui de mitu culture média
sport et politique le sujet devient
sociétale
dans la vague de révélations plusieurs
personnalités sont emportés nicolas
hulot accusé de viols et d'agressions
sexuelles
jean vincent placé condamné en 2021 pour
harcèlement sexuel ou encore denis
baupin obligé de quitter la vie
politique en 2016 après une enquête pour
agressions sexuelles sur plusieurs
femmes affaire classée sans suite pour
prescription dans ce contexte certaines
féministes réclament que les
personnalités mises en cause ne soit pas
investie élus ou nommés maintenant on
nous demande un peu aux hommes de s'en
occuper on demande un peu à ceux qui ont
la décision et le pouvoir le faire de
prendre ces décisions là de prendre
leurs responsabilités nous demande aux
hommes politiques aussi de parler aussi
comme les femmes c'est à dire de dire
quand ils savent que leurs collègues est
un agresseur de le dire parce que
souvent x avait eu ce test mais face à
cette déferlante certains laërt sur les
potentielles dérives du mouvement mis
tous nous sommes dans un état de droit
les néo féminisme ne sont pas des juges
l'émotion populaire le tribunal
médiatique ou de la rue ne doivent
jamais remplacer la justice comment
trouver le juste équilibre entre
présomption d'innocence pour l'accusé et
présomption de crédibilité pour les
femmes qui parlent c'est ce qui fait
débat aujourd'hui
christophe barbier vous diriez que le
milieu politique et plus propices que
d'autres
assez à ces violences la poussée toute
la société c'est le pouvoir qui rend
propice ces violences là c'est le
pouvoir qui est un terrain ou par lui
brise par la volonté de domination parce
que le pouvoir c'est une conquête c'est
un affrontement mais c'est vrai dans le
dans l'économie c'est vrai dans le sport
c'est vrai dans tout l'est dans tous les
sens et sans me to cette libération de
la parole là n'auraient pas eu lieu sur
bien sûr mis tout est à féliciter le
moment d'incarnation avec une affaire la
ferraille stein de cette révolution qui
est une des principales révolutions
peut-être du 21e siècle maintenant dans
leur évolution faut éviter de deux
écueils la terre retomber dans le
conservatisme en disant bon maintenant
ça suffit on en a assez parlé puis hop
c'est la restauration des privilèges
d'ancien et puis l'autre c'est la
terreur c'est l'inquisition c'est le
côté savonarole et ça il faut alors jean
saucier de travers évidemment on va
faire la godille pendant un certain
nombre de temps avant que l'essentiel
soit assurée c'est à dire un changement
culturel alors quand tu leur as bien
soin naturel qu'on se pose même plus la
question comment on y parvient pour
terminer dernier tour de table à ce
changement culturel est ce que par
exemple les hautes autorités pour la
transparence doivent regarder autre
chose que le patrimoine ou les
déclarations d'intérêts est-ce qu'il
faut pas en amont systématiquement faire
d'autres types d' enquête est ce que
c'est une une piste de solution je pense
que son étude la transparence la
moralité
encore une fois des hommes politiques
des enquêtes mais surtout encore plus
loin je pense que c'est l'égalité des
droits femmes hommes et hommes femmes
qui fera qu'on arrivera à un équilibre
etc on inversera cette donne qui est
aujourd'hui de la domination masculine
sur les femmes rapidement pour terminer
pour conclure camélia chaises et bien
écoutez europe ecologie les verts et
jeunes écologistes on est signataire
d'une charte qui savaient le mythe ou en
politique qui fait que lors des
investitures
n'importe quel signalement est pris en
compte pour éviter justement qu'on
investisse des candidats et candidates
qui serait accusée de violences sexistes
et sexuelles pardon ce christ à sa
palette pour terminer le mot de la fin
eh bien je crois qu'il est essentiel
mois que nous améliorons les conditions
de recueil de la parole et que nous
sachions mieux la déclencher ça se passe
dès l'école sans doute voyez il faut
aider ceux qui seront victimes à parler
et ensuite il faut bien traiter cette
parole mais d'aller chercher des
éléments sur la moralité voyez tout à
l'heure vous avez glissé jusqu'à dire il
y avait une plainte classée sans suite
on n'aurait pas dû le nommer vous
imaginez la justice avait décidé et la
plaignante avait la possibilité de
saisir un juge d'instruction ce qu'elle
n'a pas fait c'est difficile à faire
mais elle avait déjà saisi le procureur
elle avait la possibilité de déclencher
une autre enquête en saisissant un juge
d'instruction de la parfait et donc
cette décision judiciaire
j'entends dire on devrait quand même
parce qu'il y avait une
d'ailleurs ce que deviennent ces
signalements tu sors du helmand et
boissons du monde grâce à des traces un
avenir on verra ce que ce que décidera
la justice justement merci beaucoup
merci d'être venus débattre sur le
plateau d'el cp on va après vont
accueillir notre grand témoin elle aime
nager à contre-courant et cultive un
certain goût pour les causes perdues son
combat le plus acharné la défense des
femmes et des enfants de djihadiste
français détenus en syrie avec un
collectif d'associations elle a lancé
hier un appel solennel au chef de l'état
rapatriement pour leur rapatriement en
france on a pas mal de questions à poser
à la soprano du barreau marie dosé comme
les skis ce sujet de clément méric
si on vous invite marie dosé c'est pour
parler de deux sujets qui font
aujourd'hui l'actualité et que tout
pourrait opposer d'un côté le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 dans
lequel vous défendez un des accusés
procès qui entre dans sa dernière ligne
droite avec les plaidoiries des parties
civiles je suis la mère de victor muñoz
qui a été assassiné à la belle équipe 13
novembre 2015
la mère qui est en moi réagit de manière
très en colère dont l'actualité est
également le sort des enfants de
djihadiste français détenus en syrie
avec leur mère dont vous réclamer le
rapatriement depuis quatre ans arrêtez
les appelait les enfants dèche arrêter
les as de les appeler les enfants de
djihadistes ce sont des enfants et ce
sont maintenant malheureusement les
enfants français des camps parce que la
france les abandonne là bas le lien
entre ces deux dossiers et douloureux à
chaque fois on vous y retrouve en tant
qu'avocate pénaliste car aujourd'hui
marie dosé vous faites partie des rares
femmes à vous être imposé dans l'univers
très masculin des ténors du barreau chez
vous pas d'éclats de voix peu d'effets
de manche mais des mots choisis pour
défendre des principes qui vous tiennent
à coeur le respect de l'état de droit et
la lutte contre ce que vous appelez le
populisme pénal vos convictions on les
retrouve dans ce livre publié en 2020
les victoires de dèche vous y pointer le
double échec de la république et de la
justice française qui risque de
fabriquer les terroristes de demain est
ce qu'ils ont décidé de rejoindre l'état
islamique
est ce que ces gosses qui pour les trois
quarts au moins de 6 ans ou commis un
quelconque méfait pour que la fronde le
cid de les laisser périr et mourir dans
des camps ce qu'on est en train de faire
là aux fabriques sur mesure des
terrorismes là bas et on fabrique sur
mesure les attentats ici de demain
certains vous surnomme l'avocate des
causes perdues car on vous retrouve
souvent à contre courant de l'opinion ou
de l'air du temps l'opinion justement
pas facile pour un chef de l'état de
s'en affranchir toutes vos requêtes
auprès d' emmanuel macron sont restées
lettre morte jusqu'à présent alors marie
dosé pensez vous que la réélection du
chef de l'état pour cinq ans puisse
enfin faire aboutir votre combat pour
rapatrier ses enfants détenus en syrie
bonsoir marie dosé bonsoir et merci
d'être sur ce plateau vous allez
répondre avec les mômes eric parce que
c'est un nouveau gouvernement c'est une
réélection peut-être que les choses vont
un peu bouger notamment après la crise
est née terme est d'abord expliqué nous
au fond dans quel état
vivent ces enfants aujourd'hui qui sont
détenus dans des camps c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle des camps au nord-est
de la syrie 80 femmes 200 enfants est-ce
que l'aide humanitaire parvient toujours
est ce qu'au contraire ils sont parfois
même jusque en danger de mort alors
l'aide humanitaire parvient très
difficilement parce que ce ces enfants
ne sont pas dans un état un ils sont au
nord-est syrien le nord-ouest syrien
c'est une administration auto proclamée
par les kurdes mais ça n'est pas un état
donc l'aide humanitaire a énormément de
mal à ce cheminement jusqu'aux quand il
vit dans des conditions désastreuses 1
ce n'est pas moi qui le décrit ce sont
ce sont les associations les ong qui ont
renseigné les conditions de vie de ses
enfants ces enfants sont tous arrivés
dans ces camps il avait à peu près de
trois ans pour la grande majorité les
deux tirs les trois quarts je crois de
moins de 6 ans ils ont quel âge
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui sans il ya des adolescents
bien sûr la plupart d'entre eux sont
dans ces camps depuis trois ans depuis
la chute de l'état islamique la chute de
gbagbo en mars 2019 certains sont là
depuis cinq ans moi je connais des
enfants qui sont nés dans ces camps les
mamans sont arrivés dans ces camps est
enceinte et ils ne connaissent que le
camp de toute façon ces enfants c'est
pour ça que je suis morte plus
j'entendais votre sujet et je ce ne sont
pas les enfants de djihadistes ce ne
sont pas les enfants de dèche ce sont
des enfants français que la france
laisse périr dans des camps à la limite
ce sont les enfants des camps mais ce
sont d'abord des enfants point leur père
était combattants mais de palau mais
est-ce qu'on marque mais depuis quand
est-ce qu'on marque au fer rouge un
enfant tout à fait du crime de lier jeu
par ses passes précises que vous êtes là
l'avocate de familles d'enfants de mères
mais pas de combattants je tenais à le
préciser
alors vous dites il faut absolument
qu'ils reviennent on a compris au fond
c'est fabriquer du terrorisme que de les
laisser là bas en même temps la france
ne fait pas rien la france a une
doctrine c'est pas celle d'autres pays
mais c'est le cas par cas le
rapatriement dans le plus grand secret
en général c'est les orphelins qui
reviennent en premier ça n'est pas la
bonne approche pour vous non la france
ne fait rien je ne mangerai suffit là
depuis le mois de janvier 2021 c'est à
dire depuis 16 mois la france n'aurait
pas rien aucun enfant alors que
l'allemagne rapatrie par dizaines les
enfants et leur mère les pays-bas la
belgique les autres pays européens
rapatrie j'entendais tout à l'heure mais
actions ou m'écrit sont restées lettre
morte la france a été condamnée en
février par le comité des droits de
l'enfant de l'onu pour avoir violé la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant la france dit le comité des
droits de l'enfant de l'onu porte
atteinte à la vie de ses enfants et elle
les expose à des traitements inhumains
et dégradants en les maintenant dans ces
camps c'est le comité onusien qui le dit
donc non la france est condamnée et il
le sera probablement par le comité
contre la torture des nations unies dans
peu de temps et nous attendons la
décision de la cour européenne en fait
ce qu'il faut comprendre ce refus de
rapatrier c'est un acte de gouvernement
nous avons été obligés de saisir les
instances internationales et européennes
parce qu'on ne peut pas sanctionner un
hack de gouvernement par des
juridictions internes c'est ça la
difficulté juridique mais nous nous
battons et vous savez ce que je fais en
fait en faisant ça lorsque je demande à
à des parrains marraines de est bien de
faire un signe à ses enfants lorsque
nous avocats nous saisissons toutes ses
instances j'essaye avec les autres de
construire une autre france une autre
france que celle qui leur dit reste
là-bas et meurent parce que ses enfants
quand ils rentreront il va falloir quand
même leur écrire une autre histoire de
france justement quelle histoire et est
ce que leur mère sont prêtes à cette
histoire parce que vous dialoguez avec
certaines d'entre elles il ya des
familles en france et puis il ya les
maires sur place vous avez quelques
contacts croit savoir avec elle elles
sont prêtes elles seront jugés et hd sur
un damné et elles seront emprisonnés
bien sûr elles seront prêtes à placer
leurs enfants et donc à s'en séparer
mais non seulement elles sont prêtes
mais certaines ont réussi à s'évader des
camps et quand elle s'évade décor avec
leurs enfants c'est pas pour rejoindre
hc pour rejoindre la turquie parce
qu'elles savent qu'en turquie le
protocole cazeneuve s'applique et
qu'elles vont rentrer en france et
prépare d'ailleurs leurs enfants donc
avions prête à revenir en france ma mère
séparée
elles le savent elles savent qu'elles
sont sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
international
quelles vont être mises en examen placé
en détention provisoire et que leur
enfant sera d'abord flassans famille
d'accueil manger en famille de les
réinsérer mais ça veut dire est ce que
la france a les moyens parce que les
dispositifs sont tracés sont si inquiets
de sa rêver commandes on parle de bombes
à retardement
est ce qu'on sait faire est ce qu'on à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance suffisante
pour réinsérer réintégrer quand on voit
l'échec de la d re hakda d'éradiquer
mais la réinsertion ça concerne des
adultes ça concerne pas des enfants vous
vous rendez compte qu'on est en train
d'utiliser des termes de réinsertion
pour des gamins qui sont cinq en six ans
ce nom la force de résilience des
enfants ces enfants sont des victimes et
sont victimes de leurs parents et d'un
pays qui les abandonne ses enfants
doivent être soignés on sait faire
demandé à serge hefez demandé à boris
cyrulnik est notre porte parole qui a
pris la parole publiquement sur sa sont
boris cyrulnik enfin les enfants des
camps il les connaît serge hefez qui
s'est occupé de tous ces enfants qui
sont rentrés par ce qui en a plein qui
sont rentrés depuis 2012-2013 le dit ces
enfants vont bien moi je connais une
petite fille qui rentre et qui est
première de sa classe aujourd'hui
pendant que un autre enfant dans ces
camps me dit est ce que tu as demandé à
ma maîtresse est ce que même elle elle
veut pas que je rentre voilà ce qu'on
est en train de fabriquer donc ce terme
bombard au stade à retardement cessons
de répéter des choses comme ça même
celui qu'il a prononcé en premier qui
était françois molins sous votre
contrôle la regrettait la regrettée là
c'est vrai et en même temps vous savez
très bien pourquoi emmanuel macron
léger de tâtonnements au début on a cru
qu'il y avait un rapatriement puis
finalement il ya une enquête d'opinion
qui a montré que les français n'étaient
pas du tout prêt est ce qu'on est prêt
mais est-ce qu'il faut que la société
soit prête ou est ce que vous dites
c'est la décision du chef de l'état
arrêté de regarder les sondages sur ce
sujet moi je veux croire qu emmanuel
macron est désormais prêt d'abord parce
que ils allaient des raisons de le
croire aujourd'hui j'ai deux raisons de
le croire d'abord il ne peut pas briguer
un troisième mandat et ensuite il a tenu
à terminer le le débat avec marine le
pen par ces mots le prochain quinquennat
sera sous le sceau de la protection de
l'enfance ma priorité sera la protection
de l'enfance il ne peut pas rester le
président d'un pays condamné pour
violation de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant il
ne peut pas incarner ça il ne peut pas
incarner ça on ne peut pas nous avait
réussi à prendre contact puisque vous
vous demandez à être reçue à l'elysée
assure mais attention pas moi
vous avez peut-être su que les
associations de victimes de terrorisme
ont appelé au rapatriement de ses
enfants je parle de la fenvac je parle
de l'association 13 ans 15 vous avez
fait une conférence de presse cette
semaine avec le collectif des familles
unies avec la ligue des droits de
l'homme hwr amnesty international mais
surtout ces deux ces deux associations
de victimes de terroristes qui disent
parce que c'est un impératif humanitaire
et sécuritaire il faut sauver ses
enfants et c'est quand même fort comme
message au moment où le procès du 13
novembre 2015 et vient entre dans les
phase des plaidoiries vineyard quelques
minutes justement pour aborder ça on
vous invitera forcément si vous avez des
nouvelle à nous annoncer après une
entrevue potentiel à l'elysée on verra
on va suivre ce dossier ciel c'était
quelle place y prend dans votre vie ce
procès du 13 novembre les plaidoiries
ont commencé hier elles sont organisées
par thèmes je rappelle que vous que vous
défendez l'un des accusés ali ou le
caddie accusé d'avoir assisté salades
des flammes alors je défende accusés qui
est placé sous contrôle judiciaire il
est libre il n'est pas détenu je le
défends avec mon associé judith lévis
c'est un procès qui évidemment dure
longtemps qui a des conséquences sur nos
vies professionnelles ont marqué au
débat non mais on est on est on a tous
été bouleversés de toute façon ce sont
finalement vous savez les je sais pas
comment expliquer ça au départ j'avais
très peur de me retrouver face à une une
commission d enquête parlementaire
supra commission d'enquêté parlementaire
mais c'est pas ça je pense qu'on a
réussi malgré tout à préserver alors que
c'était difficile
ce qu'est véritablement le procès pénal
j'ai été bouleversé par certains
témoignages des victimes et évidemment
je ne m'en remettrai jamais j'ai
considéré que certains autres
témoignages n'avaient pas forcément leur
place dans une enceinte judiciaire en
tout cas je l'aï ressenti comme ça mais
voilà nous arrivons enfin dans le temps
des plaidoiries tant mieux et puis et
puis cette page judiciaire sera tournée
je pense que de toute façon en tout cas
elle elle doit être tournée d'idiomes
ans et c'est un peu ce qui est en train
de se construire christian saint palais
qui était sur votre plateau et qui est
mon confrère à côté de moi aussi à ce
procès devrait je l'espère pensaient la
même chose je crois que
en tout cas ce procès s'est tenu avec
beaucoup de dignité j'ai le sentiment
que j'ai merci beaucoup merci marie dosé
je vous propose de rester avec moi
quelques minutes encore parce que c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos a franchi pour
leur parti pris j'ai nommé ce soir elsa
monde un gabin pour son carnet de
campagne des législatives jean rémi
baudot la politique le maquereau nine
survivra-t-il à emmanuel macron est
truffé begin hochet pour l'économie
fanny qui s'interroge sur la pénurie de
lithium est-ce que ça va paralyser ou
non l'automobile hainaut a franchi les
voici bonsoir bonsoir à tous les trois
de france info une lcp on est au complet
et on commence avec vous l'annnonce du
gouvernement c'était vendredi 28 membres
pour la première ministre plus la
première ministre et elisabeth bornes ça
fait 29 mais attention à ne pas déballer
les cartons trop vite certains
pourraient ne pas rester ministre s'y
est bien ici me rien mais ils sont 14 15
ans comptant à elisabeth borne à être
candidat aux élections législatives et
pour eux la règle est claire elle a été
rappelé après le premier conseil des
ministres par la nouvelle porte parole
du gouvernement olivia grigoire
si jamais certains d'entre nous devions
ne pas recevoir la confiance majoritaire
du peuple le ministre ou les ministres
en question devront en tirer les leçons
et se retirer du gouvernement
démissionner en cas de défaite c'est une
tradition républicaine en fait elle
remonte à 2007 alain juppé ministre de
l'écologie dû développement et de
l'aménagement durables de nicolas
sarkozy ne parvient pas à garder sa
circonscription à bordeaux il s'exprime
donc le soir de sa défaite alors qui
sont les ministres on va écouter alain
juppé pardon dit archives les
bordelaises et les bordelais n'ont donc
pas souhaité que nous les représentions
à l'assemblée nationale je présenterai
dès demain matin au président de la
république et au premier ministre ma
démission
les fonctions
de ministre de l'écologie dû
développement et de l'aménagement
durables
alors c'est qu'ils sont les ministres
menacés dans cette législative alors
évidemment on peut pas calquer les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
sur les élections législatives il ya des
questions de mobilisation le camp d'en
face le l'ancrage local du candidat mais
on a quand même regarder les résultats
de la présidentielle dans les 15
circonscriptions concernées ça peut
donner une indication sur la difficulté
de la bataille dans dix d'entre elles
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête c'est
le cas dans la circonscription de la
première ministre elisabeth bornes dans
le calvados ou encore à paris ça devrait
donc aller pour clément bonne stanislas
guérini ou encore olivia grégoire des
résultats de bonne augure encore dans le
nord chez le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin ou dans l'isère pour le
nouveau ministre des relations avec le
parlement olivier verront en revanche en
revanche pardon pour 4 min ça pourrait
être plus compliquée pour damien abad
dans l'ain plus compliqué aussi pour
d'autres raisons et 11 ans après quoi on
en a débattu large gaal et franck
riester en seine-et-marne dans ces deux
circonscriptions marine le pen est
arrivé en tête au premier tour seulement
dans le pas de calais chez brigitte
bourguignon c'est même le rassemblement
national qui a fini devant emmanuel
macron et puis dans l'essonne chez un
millier de montchalin c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui a réalisé le meilleur
score au premier tour une année dernière
pour qui ça risque d'être très très
tendue c'est la secrétaire d'état à la
mer justine bénin candidate dans la 2e
circonscription de guadeloupe mélenchon
est arrivé en tête au premier tour
marine le pen au second emmanuel macron
1 n'a eu que 30 % des voix oui on suit
ça de très près sur lcp évidemment grâce
à vous et grâce à tous les magazines de
de la rédaction la politique jean rémy
alors vous nous parler ce soir de
l'avenir du maquereau nisme un projet
selon vous qui a une date de péremption
oui le maquereau nisme dont l'origine
tiens la promesse d' emmanuel macron
qu'il a formulées souvenez vous en mars
2016 c'était à amiens lors du lancement
de son mouvement politique du côté nous
devons aller plus loin non pas pour
reformer un nouveau parti je rassure et
ici tout le monde l'idée n'est pas de
faire un parti qui soit je ne sais pas
au centre gauche ou au centre ou que
sais-je c'est pas ça notre volonté c'est
d'être un mouvement qui rassemble
voilà mouvement qui rassemble pas à
droite qu'à gauche on s'en souvient
alors dans ce court extrait au delà du
fait qu'on mesure l'effet physique de
cinq ans au pouvoir il ya la matrice
originelle quand même du maquereau nisme
un concept le déplacement une île et
pragmatique on pioche à droite à gauche
on prend ce qui marche ce qui est
performant on oublie les étiquettes tous
apporté par un marketing politique
habile en marche qui a prédit théorisé
pu provoquer la mort du parti socialiste
et des républicains mais le grand centre
européen libérale et sociale et une
façade qui commence peut-être à se
fissurer ah bon vous trouvez pourtant le
parti présidentiel et tous ses alliés
ont bonne chance d'avoir la majorité aux
législatives en champ proche une
majorité et une unité pour le moment
combien de temps quelques mois peut-être
quelques petites années mais c'est comme
votre téléphone en fait le maquereau
nice mais il va subir à une obsolescence
programmée les tractations autour de la
composition du gouvernement ont mis à
jour des tensions au sein de la majorité
au sens large à la nomination
d'elizabeth dans donc plutôt à gauche
les équipes venues de la droite ont eu
l'impression de perdre du terrain et
donc en coulisse les bons étaient très
durs les manoeuvres assez radicale le
résultat il est plutôt positif pour eux
des ministres de droite qui garde à la
main sur le rang protocolaire sur bercy
sur l'intérieur sur l'armée mais ces
tensions elles ont mis en lumière la
fragilité du maquereau nisme sachez que
à gauche la gauche n'est pas en reste
loin des micros il ya toujours une pique
sur les idées ou les incarnations trop à
droite alors combien de temps emmanuel
macron gardera-t-il la main sur ses
équipes pour que tout le monde reste
dans le rang pour étouffer les
revendications
un visiteur du soir de l'elysée me
disait la réalité c'est que cette unité
droite-gauche tacitement imposé par
emmanuel macron elle n'existe pas et
alors ce nouveau gouvernement il nous
dit quoi dumas chronique chimiquement
pur ou pas eh bien il dit que cette
coupe sur l'essence programmé pour un
peu venir plus vite que prévu vous
croyez qu'un gérald darmanin longtemps
soutenir un pape ndiaye vous croyez que
la plasticité intellectuelle des manuels
macron sa capacité à faire des coups en
soufflant le chaud et le froid ça ne va
pas finir par lasser voire
chez et puis les tensions ne sont pas
juste une histoire droite gauche il se
murmure que gérald darmanin aurait des
vues sur la république en marche il est
certain que lui y voit probablement plus
loin mais il n'est pas le seul à le
faire ça commence donc à se tendre un
peu au sein la droite macro nist on sait
qu'il doit philippe tisse sa toile il
travaille pour faire venir un maximum de
députés horizon ici-même il tente aussi
de rassembler ses forces au sénat il
prépare son influence en vue de 1027
darmana et philippe ils ne partiront
plus en vacances ensemble me disait un
conseiller donc on récapitule au sein de
la macro ni la droite et la gauche se
jaugent la droite prépare la presse sur
les ruines de l air on a souvent parlé
d'une des trois blocs il risque d'y
avoir une nouvelle fragmentation d'ici
quelques temps tant qu emmanuel macron
impose le silence le maquereau nisme
vivra lourd il perdra de l'influencé ça
finira par arriver il va goûter à ce
qu'il a toujours redouté est observé à
l'époque de françois hollande la
division et la fronde de l'intérieur
vous regardez apolitique le maquereau
nisme c'est macron peut-il survivre à
maquereau j'écoutais tout cela l'art est
réjouissante perspective en l'occurrence
alors je fais taper fiction mais c'est
tout à fait intéressant et ça ne sais
pas si vous conduisez à l'électrique pas
encore je n'ai pas de permis à voulait
pas de permis un bilan réel alors des
dames auquel s'était
levé pour aller jusqu'au tribunal
n'empêche que les ventes de véhicules
électriques se sont envolés en 2021
fanni c'est pas bon pour la planète
pourquoi parce que les batteries
utilisent des métaux rares ben oui on
aurait pu croire qu'au contraire c'était
très bien de passer à l'électrique mais
on utilise du lithium pour les batteries
électriques et se lithium et bien on
commence en manque qui en tout cas on en
a besoin et on s'inquiète c'est l'
agence internationale de l'énergie qui a
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé qui dit
attention ce lithium qu'on trouve aussi
dans les téléphones par exemple et bien
les besoins vont être multipliés par six
en dix ans ce qui veut dire qu'il
faudrait de nouvelles mines puisque on
trouve ces mines que l'on extrait dans
dans des endroits comme le chili comme
la république démocratique du congo en
amérique du sud en australie bref il
faut donc il faudrait des nouvelles
mines ces métaux rares comme le cobalt
le nickel ils sont extrêmement prisé
c'est la face cachée un peu
de la voiture propre et ce lithium
forcément il est très demandé son prix
s'envolent multiplié par cinq en un an
ce qui d'ailleurs renchérit le prix des
voitures électriques en prêt est
corrélée à la demande en voitures
électriques donc et bien donc les
chiffres de ces voitures électriques
malgré tout ils sont impressionnants
puisque la demande s'envole je vous le
disais et aujourd'hui on a 10% des
voitures neuves qui sont vendues sur la
planète qui sont électriques ça fait
quand même et 6 millions 600 mille
voitures vendues l'année dernière la
moitié en chine puisque les chinois se
sont mis à l'électrique et en ce début
d'année ça marche aussi très fort 2
millions de voitures vendues ont déjà
été vendu des voitures électriques est
donc forcément et bien ce manque de
lithium ça va ralentir ça risque de
ralentir le processus d'où l'affolement
des cons des constructeurs alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait les constructeurs ils
cherchent et il essaye d'innover il
essaye de trouver des batteries sans
lithium ça existe mais c'est des modèles
qui sont très marginaux ils essayent de
sécuriser leurs approvisionnements
par exemple c'est l'anti c'est renault
ont passé des accords avec mine de
lithium en allemagne tesla elon musk dib
a écouté puisque ça risque de freiner
mon développement je vais me lancer dans
l'extraction et le raffinage de lithium
moi même et puis on cherche du lithium
partout pour vers des nouvelles mines et
il se trouve que on en a en france ah
oui on en a dans les vosges on en a dans
le massif central et on en a en bretagne
en bretagne visiblement il ya un
gisement assez conséquent de lithium
dans le finistère 66 mille tonnes quand
même de lithium mais vous la question
d'aller creuser exactement là pour le
coup les écologistes mais les locaux
disent pas question d'aller détruire
notre notre espace naturel donc on voit
bien que toutes ces questions et bien ça
risque de donner un sacré coup de frein
au développement de la voiture propre la
voiture électrique ça vous a pas trop
convaincu que vous très électrique la
red bull ni en bretagne min dans les
vosges en parce que moi je suis lorraine
vous ne pensez pas au beau jeu
on
verra c'était les emplois non bof non ok
merci merci beaucoup pour vos
différentes chroniques merci des
affranchis et merci à vous marie dosé
vous nous tenez au courant de votre
combat est pour nous merci à vous très
belle soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant avec jean pierre gratien
admis
[Musique]